hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in Section four of being in time
Heidegger proposes to us a project and
he calls this by several different names
one is fundamental ontology another that
we're trying to clarify here is the
existential analysis of design so we got
you know one word in there that that
you're probably somewhat familiar with
analysis although you may not be
entirely sure about what it means in
this context it's a word that we I think
many people use without fully
understanding to analyze things is to
break them down to distinguish them into
their parts to carry out a sort of
survey of how everything is connected
with everything else and Heidegger is
doing an analysis in that sense so what
is an existential analysis in that case
what we'll talk about that in a moment
and what's all this design business
design is the word that Heidegger uses
to discuss human beings as a kind of
being this is what is really distinctive
about us as human beings a little bit
later he's going to say that in a way
design is the closest thing to us but
it's also quite far from us so what
design is not just me as Gregory Sadler
standing here lecturing to you right now
you were also designed this doesn't mean
that it's some sort of you know Airy you
know very vague thing that's connecting
us all together in one big mentality no
you are design I am design and design is
different in you than it is in me but
there's still a fundamental similarity
to our design that allows us to
recognize each other as the same sort of
being design Heidegger says is the being
for whom its own being can be in
question or can be a matter of concern
or care design is the being which in a
certain way is connected to or
is in a certain sense all other beings
and I'm going to begin here by talking
about a passage that he references
coming from Aristotle he says that
Aristotle had said the soul of the human
being is in a certain way beings and
this was a very important notion that
then was carried forth into medieval
philosophy as he says and how is this
interpreted the soul which constitutes
this the being of human being then which
makes us what we are
discovers in its ways to be I stasis
perception no ASIS understanding
intellection however we want to say all
beings with regard to their that Ness
and what 'no stat is to say always also
in their their being so we're different
from other beings in that we do grasp
beings out there within our field of
whatever you want to call it perception
conception intellection they are for us
but not solely for us this is part of
what it means to be humanly conscious
we're also self conscious we know
ourselves to be beings in the midst of
other beings and we can be concerned
about what kind of being are we in a way
that for example the book or the
chalkboard cannot now that gives you a
little bit about what design is what
about the existential so here we want to
follow out a few distinctions that
Heidegger is going to make here when
we're talking about an analysis of
design this is something that design
does in relation to itself design makes
sense out of itself design is what
engages in interpretations of beings
whether this be through purely ontic
that is sort of you know factual observe
observational you know scientific
disciplines or whether this be in a more
ontological way through what high degree
is going to talk about as developing of
regional ontology x'
or whether this be through a more
fundamental ontology so Heidegger tells
us that Sciences can be understood as a
way in which we try to make sense out of
reality and what we do in effect as
design is we look at part of being and
we take some being as the typical being
to understand all the other ones and we
engage either in a purely ontic approach
like he says the positive sciences do or
we engage in a sort of regional ontology
where we're trying to make sense of
things we're using basic concepts and
maybe even calling them into question
and refining them further but we're not
taking design itself as our starting
point we're taking some other being
whether it be the out of the brain and
neuroscience or of you know historical
data in history or that of observations
about anything that you like you know
cells in biology or other you know
processes that are not merely physical
or chemical but but have life involved
with them we can go on and on and on
with examples of this now that is not
the same thing as an existential
analysis of design that is something
that can be helpful the the sciences and
the other disciplines can give us
interesting clues can give us guiding
you know ways to not go completely wrong
with things if we're starting to
speculate but it doesn't actually tell
us about the structures of existence for
design so he says ontology is which have
beings unlike design as their theme are
accordingly founded and motivated in the
on text structure
design itself so we need to turn to that
and we go back a little bit further he
says that that design in its it's antic
nature is that it is ontological it can
be concerned with being as a whole with
other beings with itself and he says if
we reserve the term ontology for the
explicit theoretical question the
meaning of beings then the intended
ontological character of design is to be
designated as pre ontological much of
the time that we're engaged with being
and beings we're not doing ontology
that's something that we can add to it
we are already involved ontological II
with those beings but we have to make
that what's implicit explicit so he says
how can we do this so as we call the
very being to which design can relate in
one way or another and somehow always
does relate existence now is this just
one being in the sense of an entity like
I've got this you know a piece of chalk
and I'm always relating myself spent no
it's not like that nor is it even
something like say my body instead we
should read being here in terms of the
being of beings so existence is not
something just that I have as sort of
like a predicate I exist existence is
something that I almost swim in or
continually experience all of this is my
existence
not just this all of this and this
activity of creating something for you
that you're watching is also part of my
existence and now it's part of yours as
well so existence means more than just
having being he goes on and he says
because the essential definition of this
being cannot be accomplished by
ascribing to it a what that specifies
its material com
and because its essence lies in the fact
that it in each instance has to be it's
being as its own the term design is what
we've chosen to talk about this and he
says design always understands itself in
terms of its existence he goes on says
in terms of its possibility to be itself
or not be itself now this doesn't
necessarily mean a very explicit
cognitive understanding that I'm
formulating and thinking about all the
time but every action that I do every
emotion that I have every way in which I
move involves a kind of understanding on
my part of my own existence of me in
relation to other beings and I
understand this not just in terms of an
actuality but in terms of possibilities
at every point in time there's multiple
possibilities for me Heidegger would say
now he goes on and he says existence is
decided only by each design how in the
manner of seizing upon or neglecting
such possibilities sometimes we're not
even aware of the possibilities that
exist for us sometimes they are
concealed sometimes they are disparaged
and thereby never taken seriously but
there's all sorts of possibilities at
every single moment for the design that
is me or you all the way up to the time
that we die now he goes on and he says
we come to terms with this question of
existence always only through existence
itself we this is an important point we
don't do it by trying to abstract
existence away and becoming a
transcendental subject or you know
stripping away all of our peculiarities
and individuality is what's cool about
this is that means that existential
analysis of design doesn't have to
happen over at the fancy university or
in some psychoanalytic Institute or
through some special you know self helpy
you know where they're talking about
Heidegger no it can happen for any one
of us at any point it can happen when
we're in the army
it can happen when we're you know
scrubbing a toilet
it can happen when we're serving
somebody dinner
it can happen when we're lying awake at
night unable to sleep thinking about the
mess that we've made of our life so he
goes on and he says here's the key
distinction they see represented here we
come to terms through this the question
of existence always through existence
itself we call this kind of
understanding of itself existential this
is a different term than existential
existense the L understanding what does
he mean to signify there that this is an
antic affair he says of design this is
not ontological this is merely ontic it
has to do their factual existence and so
you know what we're talking about here
is going to be distinguished from this
so if I sit down and I think about the
fact that I could have remained in the
military for life and be retired at this
point in doing something different or I
could have remained in the university
and by now I would probably you know be
an administration or I could have done
this or I could have done that all of
those are really on tick right and
they're genuine possibilities although
maybe not as possible as I'd like to
thank but they're not giving me the
existential analysis of design so let's
turn to that what gives us that he says
the question of structure aims at the
analysis of what constitutes existence
what is existence not just my existence
right here not just the possible
existences I could have had or the
potential greg's in the future you know
I was just joking with my wife yesterday
about how you know past Greg
extra work for me by not putting away
the dishes that were in the sink the
night before and what a jerk he can be
of course I'm also past Gregg right and
we can talk in our sock about ourselves
in this way because design has this this
structure of you know reflexive 'ti
we're not talking about that we're
talking about what constitutes existence
as such for you for me for design in
general now he also talks about the
coherence of these structures of
existence and he says we shall call this
existential 'ti and he says its analysis
does not have the character of an
existential understanding but rather an
existential one right so we have a
fundamentally different sort of
comportment here he says the task of an
existential analysis of design is
prescribed with regard to its
possibility and necessity in the antic
Constitution it doesn't that means that
we always have to begin from ourselves
from where we actually are the existence
that we have but we're going beyond that
we're transcending it in a certain way
so he goes on and he tells us that the
sciences and disciplines are ways of
being in which design relates to beings
that doesn't have to be but being in a
world belongs essentially to design and
this tells us one of the key things that
the ontological you know dimension the
existential analysis of design is going
to focus upon which is the world and my
being in the world we're going to
analyze that we're going to examine that
we're going to have to begin from where
we actually are but we don't want to
remain just with the on tech and we
don't want to succumb to the leur of
taking us a science or discipline as our
sort of guiding structure to begin with
we want to see what the actual
structures out there are that are deeper
than these these Sciences or disciplines
can reach so the other aspect of this
that's going to be particularly
just to look a little bit ahead is going
to be time or temporality this is being
and time right and Heidegger says that
time has been in some respects
misunderstood it's something that we
live in it's something that we exist in
and so we can carry out an existential
analysis of design by looking at how
design is in time what is the
temporalities of design now he finishes
up by by telling us that the roots of
the existential analysis for their part
are existential they are on text so
we're always grounded in the actual
being that we have the concrete factual
nature of who we are but as I put it out
Heidegger thinks that we can transcend
that without completely leaving it
behind without launching into something
that is transcendental in the sense that
it abstracts away from all of our
actuality and particularity we have
because we were already sort of swimming
in it the capacity as design through
this analysis to figure out what
constitutes existence what the
structures of existence are and that is
the task that he's setting himself in
this work
you